welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
matrix resurrections whether you found
this 4th matrix film artfully self-aware
or your feelings were a bit mixed as all
matrix sequels are pretty much coded to
make us feel there is no denying that
this film was crafted with fascinating
attention to detail that i'm gonna break
down scene by scene for all the awesome
hidden glitches in this matrix that no
one seems to be talking about so from
the get-go the warner brothers logo
flips green over the sunny warner studio
lot in burbank right down the street
from me currently this is altered from
the 1999 film which also casts the
warner lot in green suggesting that that
was starting in the matrix itself but
like this new simulation in the fourth
film the sunny city of san francisco is
really a glitzier illusion than the dull
green color tones that dominated the
simulation in the original trilogy which
really should be a tell because sf is
never this sunny really this whole film
is a meta commentary on the impact the
first matrix film had on culture and on
the way warner brothers in particular
has tried to capitalize on that
nostalgia then we open again with the
reigning green code but now the code
ascends to form the word resurrection
and the s sneaks and delayed to tease us
that this is really about more than one
resurrection then like the opening of
the first film we open with a trace
program the text reading modal 101 now a
modal is a light box window that
displays in front of other page content
a frame within a frame and 101 was neo's
apartment number in the 1999 film which
itself was a nod to the torture room of
george orwell's 1984 and gave us some
neat parallels with neo being the one
while trinity's hotel room here being
303. we see the same phone number on the
trace 312 chicago area code
555.0690 but now the voices of bugs and
seek looks like old code it feels really
familiar i love the name wordplay bugs
of course referring to bugs in code but
also bugs bunny a wisecracker who
escapes via random portals
as in bunny
and tech that listens and seek for
sequoia but also someone who seeks
unlike the operators from rapport he
projects his visual form into the
simulation a sign of how technology has
advanced over the past 60 years whereas
before the green zero led directly to
the cops flashlight now we begin in the
puddle where you can see some raining
green coat on the walls but since this
is a reflection the raining code in this
reflection is actually ascending on that
wall this is all going down once again
in the heart or the city hotel and
outside the exchange is similar i think
we can handle one little girl they're
bringing her down now you know
lieutenant your men are already dead i
think we can handle one little girl my
men are bringing her down now
hello lieutenant your men are already
dead here the agent smith line is spoken
by morpheus but a modal version of this
identity that neo actually infused with
the smith script and since this is a
moto morpheus he's not lawrence
fishburne but yaya abdulmatine ii bugs
and seek watch the whole trinity scene
go down from outside the modal serving
as stand-ins for us as they are
wondering why we are seeing this iconic
imagery again and who is really
manipulating our nostalgia in this
moment i know the story this is where he
began modal trinity runs past a sign
reading sabor a mierda or a taste of
[ __ ] in spanish and then bug slides down
a sign reading anderson's for those who
love to eat [ __ ] referring to neo's
thomas anderson identity this being his
in-joke about being forced into a role
of a corporate drone who has to eat [ __ ]
bugs hides in a key cutter shop
recalling the key maker from reloaded
who introduced us to the whole idea of a
hallway of back doors through which this
morpheus agent now grabs bugs and ends
up in neo's old apartment there's the
same blinking cursor on the monitor his
old metacortex employee badge then we
get this confusing exchange do you
understand that you are digital
sentience i know what i am just like i
know my job is to hunt down and destroy
a sentence like you while it sounds like
yaya is saying sentience hbo's captions
read my job is to hunt down and destroy
sentients like you bugs is not a
sentient sentience being the machines
who defect to join the humans like
sebede and illuminate and neo who built
this modal does not seem to learn what
cynthia's are until he meets sentience
in the real world later on so here's
what i think is going on here neo built
this whole modal to try to make sense of
the deja vu he's been feeling by his
various streams in this case the dream
of trinity's escape from the agents and
by creating this modal that's what
alerts humans like berg to find him
because otherwise the semblance masked
him from ever being found he's been
coding these memories into the design of
his games but he created this modal to
experiment with different variables of
how it really went down because think
about it he was not actually present for
trinity's escape from the agents he only
ever dreamed this which the 1999 movie
suggested by cutting straight from
trinity's escape to neo waking up in
that first scene and now part of this
modal experiment was to fuse morpheus's
identity with the agent smith script and
to test out that variable and then at
some point neo through his searching
came across the word cynthia did not
understand what it was and then ran a
new modal loop inserting it into the
script in order to try to define it but
then when he fused morpheus with the
smith code that caused this program to
glitch and start to see the code leading
to this morpheus red pilling now when
bugs recall seeing neo notice amorphous
removes his earpiece like when smith
removed his earpiece in the first film
when he went off script bugs reveals
that she was a window washer on the day
of nioh's suicide attempt of course the
window washer carriage being morpheus's
directed escape from metacortex in the
first film the path that neo did not
take and notice how at first bug sees
him as a bald man a completely different
avatar than the mask neo is later shown
to have in the mirror showing how to
each person actually neo looks different
and that this semblance program is
working in all different kinds of ways
to keep his actual appearance a mystery
meanwhile morpheus recalls seeing
raining code on the droplets of his
mirror as we saw in the first movie
droplets on glass always reflecting the
reigning code of the simulation briefly
we see him eating in that same house of
nanking restaurant where neo later meets
saty and we're trinity often attends we
also see him running on a treadmill
they're synonym for a loop and then
morpheus's mirror ripples the same way
neos did in the mirror in the first film
and bugs offers him the red and the blue
pill choice but she deconstructs what
this really means the choice is an
illusion
you already know what you have to do now
as morpheus trips bugs gives him the
blue tinted glasses i've never worn
different glasses before i met a joke
about their wearing sunglasses all the
time in the older films but now uses a
practical way to help an extracting bean
keep their grip on the blue pill
simulation a backdoor leads out of a
cinema playing the root of all evil
starring lito rodriguez leader rodriguez
is a character in the wakkowski series
sense8 and the root of all evil
referring to man's love of money another
dig at this reboot really being driven
by capitalistic greed by the movie
studio and then as they fall from the
building morpheus's screams go
electronic
the same way neo's scream transitioned
during his red pill moment
[Music]
then we find neo as thomas anderson a
game developer in this simulation who
has taken all the memories we have seen
of the matrix films and this simulation
has turned them into a game that this
guy has created and won awards for a way
of tricking him and all the people in
this reality who might remember events
from the matrix and anytime they tried
to talk to anybody about that they would
just say you mean those video games the
company through which they do all this
is another mean joke to thomas anderson
because they call it deus machina
referring to deus ex machina which was
the name of the machine central
interface that neo met in revolutions
now in our world deus ex machina refers
to the god and the machine which is an
old greek drama term where they would
lower actors in via crane when they were
playing gods to rescue the heroes from
their crises in our storytelling lexicon
it refers to divine intervention you'll
notice how matrix memorabilia covers his
desk we see a figurine of trinity's jump
and reloaded a sentinel a hand giving
the finger just like neo flipped off
smith there's also a bunch of dc
superhero figurines covering everything
and then we see a game of the year award
for 1999 which is the year the first
film came out though the game of the
year awards actually only started in
2014 so this is an example of a design
flaw in the matrix creating this false
history for neo in which he supposedly
created all these games neo and jude
attend the simulate coffee shop calling
all these things stimulation just to
address them head on so that neo just
thinks he's overthinking everything and
then here jude geeks out on the matrix
totally echoing all the real world
fanboy sentiments that lanaokowski's
probably heard about for years reading
them in online forums and then he forces
neo to talk to trinity but now here
named tiffany is not to audrey hepburn's
breakfast at tiffany's until her husband
shows up this is my husband chad
nice to meet you hey
yes chad is credited as handsome chad a
cameo by chad chaleski john wick
director who previously worked as keanu
reeves stunt double in the first matrix
chad of course is also an insult term
for the handsome basic dudes who pick up
the women that they don't really deserve
thus jude's scowl at him and you'll
notice how trinity's kid is dressed in
all blue blue hat blue backpack and she
follows them out leaving neo behind
showing how trinity is still on the blue
pill track back in his office neo's moto
gets purged notice the error code reads
missing file morph bld exe hard to owe
the city showing how the real point of
this modal was to try to figure out who
exactly morpheus was then neo's boss
smith now played by jonathan groff
quotes hugo weaving agent smith's line
to morpheus from the original film
billions of people
living out their lives
oblivious
oblivious
he has a bust in his office recreating
that slo-mo punch from revolutions and
notice that he offers neo a smoke
recalling how smith in reloaded actually
copied over the oracle who's always
smoking like a chimney now since of
course the smith code rebooted as neo's
boss in this simulation kudos to
jonathan graf for capturing the vocal
enunciations of hugo weaving in such a
cool way just with different names
different
yeah that grunt on names and that puff
on faces just some really great acting
by graf here smith says that their first
meeting was like an fbi interrogation
during this neo flashes back to the
mouth melt scene from the first film and
then smith explains i'm sure you can
understand why our beloved parent
company warner brothers has decided to
make a sequel to the trilogy one
they informed me they're gonna do it
with or without us i love this because
this whole fourth matrix film really
came about because after years of asking
the wakowskis again and again to do a
fourth film and every time the wakowskis
refused to do it eventually the studio
warner brothers really did plan to move
forward with the fourth film without the
wachowskis to which lonowkowski relented
and said okay fine i'll do it uh yeah i
guess i did
but probably under the condition that
lana could just make fun of warner
brothers as much as they wanted then at
his therapist office on the russian hill
neighborhood in san francisco which i
hiked to like a huge nerd neil patrick
harris plays the analyst the architect
of this new matrix maybe it's not as
binary as that yes the word binary
binary is of course the name of thomas's
new game series reflecting the ones and
zeroes of binary code that make up all
of this but also how smith sees him in
neo as a binary pair but i would argue
this film overall is saying neo and
trinity don't really fall into that they
aren't opposing compliments of each
other one on the other off but rather
they share the same soul in a way they
are post-binary they break the loop they
do not correspond to code you'll notice
the analyst is framed in blue blue
framed glasses a blue sweater blue
butterfly framed on the shelf and he
prescribes blue pills the pills that
keep you part of the program and if you
look closely the bottle label reads
antalofloxin that is based on the term
ontology which is a branch of
metaphysics that explores the nature of
being and when neo takes these pills in
the mirror his reflection shows a
completely different man than before
this is actually actor steven roy in
real life carrie anne moss's husband
this is such a cool meta way of showing
that neo's true self is really meant to
be someone partnered with carrie anne
moss trinity now if you're like me and
spend a lot of days staring at screens
you might notice sore eyes and problems
sleeping blue light damages our eyes and
leads to digital eye strain the symptoms
of which include blurred vision
headaches and dry watery eyes for some
folks this can even affect your energy
level well blue blocks was created to
fix this problem and block out the blue
light with some high quality lenses
thank you to blue blocks for sponsoring
this video blue blocks are
evidence-backed and made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia when
i'm spending time in fluorescent
lighting staring at screens these
glasses are a huge help they have over
40 styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers blue blocks also has other
amazing products such as low blue light
bulbs red light therapy devices and
sleep masks i'm a huge fan of they ship
worldwide in rapid time and make returns
in exchanges easy so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
that's blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20 off
and thanks again to blueblocks for
sponsoring this episode christina ricci
plays marketing executive gwen de vere
and leads his super repetitive
brainstorming montage all set to the
music of jefferson airplane's white
rabbit keeping of course with the series
alice in wonderland motif it includes
lyrics on pill popping this song was
also memorably featured in another sf
set film the game by david fincher in
which a protagonist is similarly
gaslighted the whole time neo notices
the odd flight pattern of the birds he
loops on his treadmill he fights in his
home along to the movie fist of legend
which is a big influence that led to the
wachowskis seeking out yuen wu ping to
fight choreograph the first film wish
they got him back for this one but i
love how the looped conversations have
this really cool transition here she's
right matrix is mind bone
philosophy shiny type bbc yeah yeah that
developer sentence rolls right through a
jump cut to him in an entirely different
meeting to show me how neo finds himself
in the same looped debate again and
again over the matrix's real deeper
meaning and of course these dopes show
up again in a post-credits scene to
pitch the cat tricks
in the bathroom the toilet paper is
labeled pull for an arts degree and then
people wrote look right look left on the
door is written master bait up for a
good time call 818 wall po something
there's a sticker this guy is the
resurrection's co-cinematographer john
toll who actually worked on cloud
outlets and sense8 and then this quote
it is so much simpler to bury reality
than it is to dispose of dreams this is
from dawn dalilo post-modernism author
directly from his brook americana from
1971 which investigates film's ability
to misrepresent reality which is
basically the thesis of this film then
in that house of nanking restaurant
thomas meets adult sati the kid from
resurrections she's reading lewis
carroll's through the looking glass and
contrasting the analyst she wears red
framed glasses the color trying to break
you out of the simulation now if you
remember back in the first matrix film
neo pointed to a restaurant that served
great noodles this could be that
restaurant during this montage they
modulate the song
[Music]
yeah the word fall echoes fall fall fall
fall triggering neo-suicide attempt
during this neo eat some rare steak
looking delicious calling back cipher's
delicious looking steak that he when he
betrays morpheus to the agents neo sits
in a bathtub with a rubber ducky on his
head a reference to rubber duck
debugging where a coder would keep a
rubber duck by his desktop so he could
explain each step of his debugging to
the duck neo and trinity chat at
simulate where that barista is named
scrotchy named after comic artists and
storyboarder steve scrotchy who drew the
precise storyboards famously used to
pitch that first matrix film to warner
brothers that eventually won over the
studio to greenlight this ambitious film
concept tiff says about her husband chad
i wanted to kick him
so hard
not too hard maybe just hard enough to
break his jaw off foreshadowing how she
handles that analyst at the end of the
film and if you look closely neo sees a
reflection in that coffee table she too
has a different face and head of hair
showing how she also looks different to
the rest of the world the matrix hiding
trinity's real identity and why chad
laughed at her for seeing a resemblance
between herself and trinity in the game
now back at deis machina the developer
on the left is a cameo by donald mustard
of epic games in fortnite and then neo
gets the same kind of text as that phone
call he got from morpheus while in
metacortex in the 1999 film and then he
finds morpheus in the bathroom at last
i
wasn't too sure about the callback but
you know just hard to resist what
morpheus uno reveal at the window
lightning thunder and theater yes he's
referring to the whole theatricality of
neo's first meeting with morpheus in the
99 film at last
then smith walks into the shootout and
only upon picking up the desert eagle
mark 19 pistol does his original coding
return and take over
mr anderson
yeah he cracks his neck recalling agent
smith cracking his neck during that
subway fight and he says mr anderson the
simulation name that smith insisted on
calling neo flashing back to smith's
scream during their final battle and
revolutions here neo sees the deja vu
cat and he returns to the analyst office
where we learn that cat is actually
named deja vu another part of the
analyst gaslighting to justify why neo
would associate a black cat with the
word deja vu just like how he made him
think all of his matrix experiences were
just from the video game we see the
rooftop party that neo flashes back to
was actually lined with red and bright
blue color decor triggering him for red
pilling and blue pilling although
servers were even dressed in neo's
clothes from reloaded but back at night
bug stops neil from jumping referring to
herself as any other copper top which
was switch's term for plugged in human
batteries from the first film and then
bugs warns they don't look like typical
agents
they use bots now skinned as normal
people which means they're everywhere
and you never know who to trust another
commentary about how many social media
users are really just bots and she
reveals her rabbit tattoo calling back
to jor's rabbit tattoo also you'll
notice bugs this shirt shows a carrot
what's up bugs and seek take neo through
a portal to this tokyo train saying they
don't have to run to phone booths
anymore referring to the landlines they
previously used and very briefly as they
whizzed past those cherry blossoms
you'll notice some green code streaks by
showing how using moving portals
glitches the system so they bring neo
into the cinema projecting footage from
the 1999 film the red pill scene which
in this case was just a cut scene from
thomas's game that tear right down the
screen divides morpheus's hands which
are also divided into the red pill side
of the blue pill side in his mirror
sunglasses and neo reaches out for the
pill but we get another parallel sink
with that film
remember
all i'm offering is the truth
wait
yeah neo says wait the same time
morpheus did before as neo learns more
about what happened morpheus teases that
theory that neo might have actually been
working with the machines referencing
the theory that some fans had that since
we learned that the neo we've been
following was really the sixth iteration
of the anomaly that all of this could
have just been part of the coded loop
that the machines wanted to happen and
as in as red pilling before neo touches
a mirror and it ripples but in this case
it connects him back to the analyst
alerting that analyst that neo has been
found so they have to flee back on that
bullet train where the machines activate
a bot swarm one passenger wears a mask
covered in japanese matrix code but that
pattern fills each of their eyes when
they convert into bots so neo has to get
unplugged and he boards the nema sign or
nemosine in greek mythology the nema
sign was the goddess of memory they plug
him back into the construct renew
immediately touches the back of his head
just like he did upon entering the
contract the first time we see morpheus
old tv set playing a series of clips
from the past films morpheus transports
him to the lake dojo where he forces him
to fight to combat the effects of the
blue pill withdrawal at one point yaya
does a similar footwork that lawrence
fishburne did when they fought before
aboard the nema sign bugs reveals that
the oracle had been purged but that neo
and trinity sacrifices gave them a mixed
piece with some of the machines called
cynthians these include sabebay
obstacles and luminate the crew includes
the pilot hanno as well as lexi their
neologist berg who is the one who found
neo's modal elster she's the
granddaughter of roland from reloaded
and resurrections and of course we met
sikh sequoia he does not have plugs
because he was born in the real world
like tank and dozer were morpheus now
appears as an exomorphic particle codex
similar to that machine interface of
deus ex machina in revolutions and they
enter the new human city named io a moon
of jupiter also from greek mythology the
name of one of zeus's mortal lovers whom
hera was really jealous of so zeus
transformed io into a cow to hide her
from hera io went to all kinds of
suffering but she actually later gave
birth to zeus's children and became the
ancestress to the great greek hero of
heracles but the word io is essentially
zion with the z and the n removed making
this city a kind of zion but with no
beginning and no end jada pinkett smith
returns as niobe who catches up with neo
a long way from dozer's paint stripper
calling back the booze that cipher gave
to neo that dozer brood
good [ __ ] huh
dozer makes it
good for two things
degrease in engines and killing brain
cells
one of the many improved sabori scene
mierda thanks to the human synthetic
garden we learned about morpheus's
election and the machine's civil war and
neomed shepherd who mentions that viral
agent referring to when smith used the
human body of bane to enter the real
world and reloaded in revolutions they
go back in enter in a hotel room with a
viking bust this prop was actually from
maravingian's mansion and reloaded
foreshadowing his coming return in the
next scene but first they run into smith
sounds like conflict
inevitable yes the word inevitable
calling back their battle and
revolutions there's nowhere i can't go
there is nowhere i won't find you
it's impossible
not impossible
inevitable
and so the exiles return including the
dirty merovingian we had conversation
you gave us faith
neo says
calling back his line in the first film
i know kung fu smith tackles them into
the basement just like old times as we
flashback to their various duels
throughout the trilogy neo and smith
actually mirror each other's attacks
perfectly now proving how well these two
fighters know each other then smith
rapid punches his ribs just as he did in
the first film neo coughs up blood as he
did in the first film as well he finds
trinity who melts into code deja vu
appears and the analyst shows up allow
me to sum up our goal in a single word
bullet time
[Music]
it's two words but the analyst is
echoing jude's pitch to signal that jude
was really his puppet spying on neo and
that they both preached the same kind of
shitty philosophy about praying on
people's fears and their conspiracy
beliefs the way in our world now online
algorithms totally do to users we have
voluntarily plugged into the machines
but the cynthian kujaku brings naobi and
neo to sati who reveals that her father
who we saw in revolutions was one who
built that anomaly that neo and trinity
were sequestered in so they mount a
rescue and while they work to unplug
trinity neo meets trinity at that
simulate shop after a conversation
trinity initially decides to go back
with chad and her kids but chad really
makes the mistake of continuing to call
her tiffany which is really the trigger
that sets her off i wish you would
stop calling me that i hate that name
my name is trinity
and you better take your hands off of me
during the battle one of the members of
the crew is named calliope
this is actually a cameo by san
francisco mayor london breed they flee
the bot swarm to this rooftop where a
helicopter unloads on them the shells
falling down on us just like when neo
and trinity fired at the agents holding
morpheus after the explosion trinity
awakens and sees that same flock of
birds which shimmer into code you can
also see code raining down the nearby
skyscraper all showing how trinity is
really the second half of that anomaly
who shares neo's abilities so when they
leave notice how neo panics and kicks
through the air just as he did in his
first jump program and he falls again
while trinity keeps her pose the entire
time because she has bird-like
confidence and in the way that neo broke
the cycle to rescue trinity back in
matrix reloaded by walking out of the
other door from the architect's room it
is really the love between these
characters that makes them revolutionary
this is what the analyst was explaining
when he said he needed both of them to
be able to make this version of the
matrix so they fly back to the analyst
trinity breaks his jaw off yeah i love
how you can see green code underneath
the skin whenever she cuts them and they
thank him you gave us something we never
thought we could have
and what is that
another chance
and the music we hear is a female cover
of rage against machines wake up in this
case by brass mirroring the end of the
first film and as they fly into the
sunrise they shattered that dumb flock
of birds that representing the loop that
they were trapped in but not anymore so
i'm really curious to know all of your
thoughts on this film so leave those in
the comments below and you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching sheeple
[Music]
you